[Music]
actually i've got something here at the
bottom
uh i just wrote this down myself so a
few people asked this question last time
i talked about not having internet at
home
and i said
i don't have internet at home and
people ask well how do you
what do you do
like
what do you mean what do you mean on the
internet yeah but you like have a phone
at home right and it's like well not
really actually
where we live doesn't get great service
especially in the home yeah there are
certain parts of the house to get one
bar so you could get really horrible
service if you're like standing on one
leg and your head's popped out the
window and you're rubbing your tummy and
patting your head at the same time right
you'll get one bar of signal and so
several people ask me what do you do now
that you don't have home internet it's
not that i'm opposed to home internet
the problem is as david foster wallace
said
if i can get out they can get in
now this isn't conspiracy theory like oh
they're going to watch me
no it means like if i have the ability
to get out and access all the news and
the panic and the social media 24 hours
a day seven days a week then they also
have access to my thoughts yes in the
sense that like they can
it's mind control
in a roundabout way it is because what
i'm really saying here is
i don't want everyone else's emergency
dictating my day everyone else's panic
everyone else's urgent task or urgent
need yeah dictating how i spend my day
so there are a few things that i do
when i'm bored that's what someone asked
you don't have internet at home so what
do you do when you're bored
well the three big things i like to do
every morning is read write and exercise
yeah and it's simple bodyweight
exercises we still have that on on the
website i still do the same exercises
every day 18 minutes of push-ups
pull-ups and squats i even throw a few
weights in there occasionally i have
some adjustable weights that i have
but 18 minutes a day why 18 minutes well
because it takes about 18 minutes to get
exhausted but also everyone has 18
minutes in a day so no one has an excuse
anymore yeah you can find 18 minutes
somewhere at some point during the day i
prefer to do it in the morning but i
actually enjoy these exercises now
because i'm not forcing myself to go to
the gym and put on the right fitness
equipment and
make sure i use the right routine and
the app and all these other things no
it's push-ups pull up squats repeat
pretty simple yeah i uh read every day
yeah fiction nonfiction
doesn't really matter but
now that i don't have all of the glowing
screens to interrupt me all the time
i rediscovered books
and they're awesome
and it could even be picture books i can
still look at pictures the 150 best
minimalist house ideas i could read this
that's reading and so
i love reading novels you know the dave
edgar's novel i talked about a few weeks
ago on the podcast the every or jonathan
friends and you know wrote the
book called crossroads which is my
favorite novel maybe ever right uh
anything by david foster wall so i have
a curated book collection but i also
read on a kindle as well which is a
glowing screen
but it's not one that can constantly
distract me right because i don't have
instagram on it yeah
what else do i do here
um
i write almost every day
and i talked to my writing students over
at howtowritebetter.org
how to write every day
and because it becomes a priority i eat
food every day yup i also write every
day i exercise every day i read every
day these things are a priority for me
sex not something i do every day but
without all the glowing screens and the
internet interruptions
there is more sex i'm sure there are
there is and then sometimes i just sit
quietly without stimuli
get out of here unbelievable
it's yeah go ahead one of my favorite
quotes is from pascal he said all of
humanity's problems stem from man's
inability to sit quietly in a room
alone
it's interesting because there's a
balance with all of this
like
too much stimuli
will um
what will stress you out
not enough stimuli
you uh
you get cabin fever i was watching this
study on it was mythbusters a very
scientific show
they were doing studies on uh
cabin fever
and essentially they you know put these
men in uh separate rooms and like did
some experiments to see how they did
and uh they all had to
have some sort of stimuli and and
basically though they were positing that
yes cabin fever is a real thing but the
stimuli was very simple it wasn't like
um that's the key yeah it wasn't it
wasn't tvs it wasn't glowing screens it
wasn't like game it was
it was uh either like looking out to a
picturesque you know scenery
or um one of the guys uh like took a
coat hanger and like
you know cut it up and made some kind of
mechanical thing out of it you know
because that's that was his hobby
essentially
so um yes we do need some stimuli um but
we don't we don't need as much as the
typical household has
i've noticed my daughter
just out in the yard sitting there
watching
the
hummingbirds
and hearing them like she's become so
sensitive to the she can hear them and
sense them almost
that is stimuli yeah and what i've
noticed now that we have more access to
nature you know we moved to the small
town
in ventura county only about 8 000
people
and we have a lot of access to nature we
can still make it to the city if we need
to be but we're withdrawn enough
that the stimuli is more subtle yeah and
i've noticed my daughter's
right her her nervous system has
regulated self-regulation my wife's
nervous system has self-regulated mind
is beginning to regulate as well
as
yes there is stimuli it's not being
locked in a padded room with a straight
jacket on right but it's removing 99 of
the stimuli this is what minimalism does
whether it's minimalist architecture or
it is minimalist lifestyle minimalist
literature it's removing the excess
stimuli
so we can focus
on what is essential
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free